How in the world did our nation's economic
advisers go from ridiculing tariffs and subsidies-
Trade protectionism would be one of the stupidest
things we could possibly do.
It was one of the causes of the Great Depression.
To promoting pure protectionism.
The steel industry must be kept aloft despite
the fact that it's always getting help.
You know what I would do?
I would subsidize it.
The answer lies in the paradigm shifting,
reality distorting and frequently cringe inducing power
of power itself.
I hear something, it's Ronald Reagan rolling
over in his grave!
What are you talking about!?
It's a revolutionary thought-
My fellow Americans, it's sometimes said
that if you put three economists in a room
and ask them a question
you're liable to get more than three answers.
This is the sad story of a team of presidential
advisers with two opinions for every man.
Before Trump took office they stood for a
principle that conservatives,
at least rhetorically, have championed for
decades.
Free and fair trade brings growth and opportunity
and creates jobs
and they all warn that high trade barriers,
what is often called protectionism,
undermines economic growth and destroys jobs.
Following in this tradition was Mike Pence.
You can see that our existing trade agreements
have truly benefited Indiana
and the entire United States.
As a member of the House of Representatives
Pence voted to normalize trade regulations
with China,
he praised NAFTA, voted for the Central American
Free Trade Agreement,
supported the Trans Pacific Partnership and
backed free trade agreements
with Australia, Singapore, Chile and Peru.
I did not come to Washington to ask working
Americans
to subsidize the bad decisions of corporate
America.
Even though Pence represented a state with
over a hundred thousand auto workers
he voted against then president Obama's corporate
bailouts out of principle.
Donald Trump will choose Indiana Governor
Mike Pence to be his running mate.
After joining team Trump, Pence was a changed
man.
Rescued from an unpopular governorship, Pence
was thrust into the national spotlight
and his political career was given a new life.
His conversion to protectionism was so sudden
and complete
he had a hard time convincing journalists
his new faith was sincere.
So are you for the 35% tariff?
Let me go back to the intervening part.
Are you for the tariff though for the-
The carrier, well I'm for us putting everything
on the table in negotiations
in renegotiating NAFTA.
You're supporting the Trans Pacific Partnership
that Mr Trump says would rape this country.
As Pence hit the talk show circuit
we learned that every free trade agreement
he had supported his entire political career
was now a bad deal and up for renegotiation.
I support free trade and so does Donald Trump.
Not really-
I do-
The United States under successive administrations
has been negotiating really bad trade deals-
A month before he was sworn in as Vice President
Pence went from badmouthing banking bailouts
to bankrolling the Carrier corporation in
his home state.
Just one year after supporting free trade
with China
he now declared it enemy number one.
China is not an ally, China is an adversary
of the United States.
At about the same time Trump's campaign adviser
Stephen Moore
and White House Chief of Staff Reince Priebus
were stressing key elements of protection
in their speeches and public appearances.
Donald Trump wants to bring jobs back from
overseas
and hold companies who want to send them abroad
accountable.
We should not have free trade with China
if they're going to continue to steal five
hundred billion dollars a year from us, right?
Moore told a group of top Republicans that
the GOP
was no longer the party of Ronald Reagan.
The bedrock undernea th the Republican party
is shifting at the rate of one presidential
adviser at a time.
After a year in office, members of Trump's
economic team
have either adopted the Commander in Chiefs
line on trade-
Tariffs are important to preserve the steel
industry.
Kept a low profile, or have resigned.
This is Gary Cohn's last meeting in the cabinet
and of the cabinet
and he's been terrific, he may be a globalist
but I still like him.
As the United States follows other countries
down the path of economic nationalism
advocates for free trade are losing their
voice.
Fewer are making a compelling public case
for free trade
as Milton Freedman did for decades.
You know let's suppose three of us are out
in a boat in the ocean.
And one of the fellas out there takes out
a gun and shoots holes in the bottom of the boat.
Is it the sensible thing for the others of
us to do
to take out our guns and shoot more holes
in the bottom of the boat?
That's kind of a silly notion isn't it?
But yet that is exactly the notion of protection
and retaliation.
Which are the same arguments that Moore, Preibus,
Kudlow and Vice President Pence
all made before joining team Trump.
And as Ronald Reagan believed only inconsistently
during the 1980s.
This legislation will enable us to enforce
steel export restraints,
guard against unfair import surges into the
American market
and help keep the United States from becoming
the world's steel dump.
Although NAFTA and the precursor to the World
Trade Organization
were born from his administration,
Reagan also raised a punitive 100% tariff
on Japanese electronics,
a 45% tariff on Japanese motorcycles,
he slapped export quotas on cars and machine
tools and Canadian lumber and sugar.
Just enough economic nationalism to make our
current protectionist in chief proud.
Frankly Ronald Reagan, I loved his style,
his attitude,
he was a great cheerleader for our, for you
know the country but not great on the trade.
All of which is to say maybe President Trump
is more Reagan-esque
than even he gives himself credit for.